le film que je recommande et l'événement
de Audrey divane l'événement raconte un
rite de passage tout particulier puisque
c'est celui d'une jeune femme qui se
trouve confrontée au choix d'avorter
mais malheureusement pas dans les
conditions qu'on aimerait puisqu'il
s'agit d'un film d'époque et que cette
jeune femme est une étudiante brillante
dans le cœur de la France des années 60
ça y est c'est fini vous allez vous
allez rater vos examens
oui non
ce que j'ai trouvé formidable dans ce
film c'est à quel point il ne fait pas
de cadeau au sujet de l'avortement il
est vraiment très cru par rapport à la
réalité et ils m'ont certaine manière la
réalité notamment à travers des
personnages et une interprétation des
acteurs qui est
absolument exceptionnel ce qui est très
intéressant aussi dans ce film c'est le
travail sur la lumière et le travail sur
les décors qui d'une certaine manière
font vraiment partie intégrante de ce
rythme initiatique un petit peu un petit
peu macabre et un petit peu un petit peu
qui fait malheureusement écho avec la
période actuelle et ce que j'admire
énormément finalement dans le travail
d'audredivan c'est à quel point elle a
pu traiter ce sujet extrêmement délicat
de manière à faire vivre une expérience
au public qui permet de questionner et
de faire vivre le sujet de l'avortement
puisque comme pour n'importe quel sujet
il est important surtout d'en parler et
de continuer d'éduquer afin de protéger
des droits qui sont fondamentaux mais
qu'il faut toujours continuer à
conserver et à ne jamais considérer
comme acquis